LEGAL REFUGE.
>> Tucker: THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY COUNTRY WHERE THESE
DEBATES OR THE REALITY OF
PEOPLE MOVING ACROSS BORDERS
WITHOUT PERMISSION IS
UNFOLDING.
IN ITALY, SOMETHING VERY
SIMILAR IS HAPPENING.
ITALIAN INVESTIGATORS
RECENTLY STOPPED A HUMAN
SMUGGLING OPERATION, ONE
THAT BROUGHT ISLAMIC
EXTREMIST INTO EUROPE.
THEY WERE POSING AS ASYLUM
SEEKERS.
SO FAR NO ONE HAS ACCUSED
THE ITALIAN POLICE OF
RACISM.
WHY IS THAT?
NIGEL FARAGE, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU WATCHED THE
DEBATE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER IN
THE UNITED STATES.
DOES IT REMIND YOU OF THINGS
YOU HAVE SEEN IN EUROPE.
>> FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN THE
MEDITERRANEAN CRISIS BROKE I
SAID IN THE EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT WE MUST NOT LET
OUR PASSION IMPERIL OUR
CIVILIZATION BECAUSE ISIS
WILL USE THE MEDITERRANEAN
ROUTE TO GET THEIR
OPERATIVES INTO EUROPE.
SURE ENOUGH LAST YEAR WE
WERE WARNED BY INTERPOL UP
TO 50 JIHADDISTS HAD COME
INTO ITALY ALREADY AND TODAY
THIS GANG, AS YOU HAVE
ANNOUNCED HAS BEEN FOUND,
IT'S BEEN BUSTED AND THEY
HAVE BEEN BRINGING JIHADIS
IN.
WHAT CLEARER LESSON CAN
THERE BE OF THE GREAT
SELF-HARM YOU CAN DO TO YOUR
FACE CIVILIZATION.
SAFETY OF YOUR CITIZENS IF
YOU DON'T SEND OUT A MESSAGE
THAT PEOPLE CANNOT JUST
ILLEGALLY COME INTO YOUR
COUNTRY.
I SEE WHAT'S GOING ON TODAY
DOWN IN TEXAS.
I WOULD STY AMERICANS JUST
LOOK AT THIS NEWS STORY.
LOOK AT ISIS PREYING ON THE
WEAKNESS OF GOVERNMENT OVER
BORDERS AND THAT TELLS ME
THAT TRUMP IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WITH EVERYTHING THAT
HE IS SAYING.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S SO
INTERESTING IS THAT Y'ALL
HAVE BEEN HAVING THESE
DEBATES LONGER THAN WE HAVE
BEEN IN THE UNITED STATES.
ONLY TRUMP GOT THE DEBATE
OUT IN THE OPEN TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT HAS BEEN.
IT DOES SEEM LIKE THE
CONSENSUS IN EUROPE IS
CHANGING.
I READ A STORY TODAY ABOUT
EVEN THE LEFT IN EUROPE IS
STARTING TO THINK MAYBE
BORDERS ARE IMPORTANT.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN.
WE HAVE REACHED A POINT
WHERE, YOU KNOW, AMONGST THE
GENERAL POPULATION.
OVER 70% IN MOST COUNTRIES
PEOPLE ARE SAYING WHOA, THIS
IS CRAZY.
AND, YOU KNOW, TUCKER, IT'S
NOT JUST TERRORISM.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN PLACES LIKE
SWEDEN, WHAT'S HAPPENED IN
PLACES LIKE GERMANY WHERE
HUGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE FROM
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
CULTURE HAVE SETTLED IN
THOSE CITIES WITH ALL SORTS
OF OTHER SEXUAL CRIME AND
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE COME TO.
SO OVERWHELMINGLY, EUROPEANS
THIS MADNESS HAS TO STOP.
AND WE ARE SEEING POLITICAL
CHANGE.
NOW, WE ARE NOT SEEING IT
FROM MRS. MERKEL.
WE ARE NOT SEEING IT FROM
PRESIDENT MACRON OF FRANCE.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE IN MAY THIS YEAR, IN
ELECTIONS TO THE EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT ASK
PARLIAMENT ISK
PARLIAMENT IS A MASSIVE
SHIFT IN TERMS OF POLITICAL
DIRECTION CONTROLLING
BORDERS IS BECOMING
FASHIONABLE AGAIN IN